and we are live welcome everybody to
know that YouTube hangout super excited
to be here with you and a new friend of
mine
Kendrick Shope is with me and she is new
to the channel and new to me so super
excited to have her on board welcome
aboard
thank you so much it is my honor to be
here I've watched a lot of not I'm not
too new to your channel in the way that
I've watched a lot of a lot of your
interviews so I'm thrilled to be here I
love it what's one of your favorite um I
watched one this morning with oh I'm
gonna be embarrassed oh and it was one
of my very favorites you put me on the
spot I can't remember I'm but it'll come
to me in the middle of this it'll kind
of to just stick with me don't kind of
take me Louis Louis Louis Louis lose
house okay yeah I loved hearing his
story
I never blue isn't but I loved hearing a
story about being an athlete and the
transition and how he got to what he's
doing now it was all very fascinating to
me I didn't that was background so it
was really really interesting cool yeah
lewis has amazing stuff and it was fun
to have money for my audience who may
not be super familiar with you yes can
you give them the overview of what
Kendrick Shope is all about yeah
absolutely it'd be my honor so Kendrick
show is about a lot of things but as
it's relevant to your audience
I teach entrepreneurs mainly women
entrepreneurs how to sell without
sacrificing their integrity some of this
is based in gender research so the
differences in the way men and women
sell the difference is the differences
between the male and the female brain
some of its based in socialization so
gender science and gender socialization
and some of it is based in good old
fashioned experience I was a top
performing sales rep for about two
decades and left five years ago to start
my own business and created authentic
selling it's it's it's interesting to me
that that people even think that they
have to sacrifice their integrity the
cell that that's even a question and I
know I know a lot
will do and they feel like they you know
they're lying to get the Sailor you know
they have to go against their values to
get the sale from my experience when you
act with integrity that's when you
actually get the best sales the better
sales the ideal clients the people who
love what you're all about
so it's interesting like it's almost sad
that that we need to have this
conversation to teach people that you
need to act with integrity I wish it was
more kind of ingrained in our culture
and in our upbringing what are what are
some of the what are some of the common
things that you find people have to
sacrifice their values over and then how
do they come back that yeah well I don't
know that I don't think it's any real
shocker that people want to act out of
integrity I mean I I'm with you I don't
think that that is that that is anything
that that people are surprised about but
I think that where the the issue comes
in for people is they don't necessarily
know how so not not to act with
integrity but how to sell with integrity
and they're two different things because
we've all heard the story of the
stereotypical used-car salesmen or the
traveling medicine man you know who's
gonna sell you the cure to make you 10
years younger and cure all your problems
and it's liquor and he's got in the next
day so selling gets a bad rap through
its history and through its stories
something also gets a bad rap because
we've all likely had a negative sales
experience where somebody's pushed
something on us and we either had
buyer's remorse or we felt guilty or
whatever that's we're selling with
integrity comes in it's like one bad
apple has time to bring the whole bunch
for people to have greatness to share
but don't want to push it on people and
so my message to people and what allows
people to be so successful successful
who work with me as we overcome that we
go back to the basics of selling is the
exchange of money for a product or
service there's nothing icky sleazy
slimy pushy or out of integrity about
that and really at its core selling is
helping that's that's the beginning of
what it means to sell with integrity so
I don't think that it's it's a shocker
that people who sells integrity make
more money I don't think that it's
rockets
that we need to act out of integrity I
think that the catch-22 is people don't
necessarily know how because of the bad
reputation selling yes does that make
sense yeah no I agree I think there may
not be enough quality training to like
you we don't learn how to do this in
school you know you're when you enter
into a company you're just opinion on
there their sales training process we're
getting some questions coming in live
and might be helpful to answer some of
those two the first one comes in from
Paul who says I've made a website about
selling pages to guitar tutors who's
trying to sell the guitar tutors and I
guess make a give them different
websites and is wondering how you can
use how we can get some sales and how
integrity selling can help him land more
clients for his guitar Twitter page yeah
so that's a great question I think it
depends on exactly what you're doing I
don't think we live in a market anymore
where you just put a page up and you
build it and they come I think you've
got to ask yourself how do we create
some buzz about this so obviously the
easiest answer there is social media
right you want to get a megaphone
through social media and talk about how
what you're offering is different how it
can help people how it can help them to
play you know train people to play the
guitar better how can help people play
whatever whatever you're selling people
think that social media is a lot of
noise and it can be so you've got to
make sure that the information that
you're putting out there is targeted
towards benefits and pain points what's
the overall benefit of your service how
does that change somebody's life ability
to play the guitar whatever and that's
what you want to focus on so I don't
think we're in an era anymore where you
can just build it and they'll come I
think you've got to create some
promotion and you've got to create some
excitement about what you're doing yeah
if I have found a website geared towards
guitar tutors the Newmark of their
business I would try to give them just
like there may not be enough great sales
training out there especially if you are
an entrepreneur if you're a guitar tutor
and you know maybe you're a teacher
maybe you're a janitor or whatever
you're doing during your spare time
zero training about sales of being an
entrepreneur and so I would love to see
Paul you give information to these
guitar tutors on how to run a business
as well give them feedback give them
advice maybe interview other guitar
tutors who had a successful career and
like has made this their full time
income because if you can do that and
help them build a business and give the
knowledge education and training then
it's a no-brainer to want to sign up for
what you're doing in you know tell their
friends about it bring you referrals I
think it's easy just to get up just to
get caught up in the what you offer and
that's all I do we're really if you want
to have success you got to think above
and beyond you got to give them a reason
to really want to talk about you and
give them an amazing experience so I
think that would be super helpful and I
think would be something that help
spread the word within that community
yeah I would agree
Renee is running in I owned a commercial
cleaning company in Texas where are you
based by the way I'm in Arkansas
Arkansas I'm sorry I have to say it so
yeah I'm not a hog I'm a Tennessean all
right well I'm from I'm Canadian so
you're closer to Texas and I am Rene
so I own a commercial cleaning company
in Texas my integrity shows in person
but I'm not sure how to translate
content and advertising so I guess you
know we've have been a great experience
himself going and talking to people how
do you then turn that into marketing on
your website and all the content that
you're creating yeah that's a great
question so I think that the first thing
and some of these are really simple
someone's not rocket science but the
first thing I would ask is when you're
in person why does it translate what is
it that you're doing that makes it
translate so well and then how do is it
the words that you're using isn't the
way that you're saying it is the
excitement that is it the job that you
do is the testimonials that you get and
how can you extrapolate that and put it
onto your website and put it out in the
black and white copy that you have so I
think the first thing is obviously
you're doing a great job in person what
is it about that that makes you so
confident that you that it's translating
and how do we do that in print yeah I
look to like if you try to understand
what your skills are are you a great
writer
can you write copy for your website or
do you hate the idea of having to write
you know are you good at potentially
being on camera and telling your story
about why you started this cleaning
company cleaning companies especially in
commercial is so price driven but if you
can tell me your story
and if I feel like you know you're gonna
cheat my office building like it's your
mom's house then I'm attached to your
story a little bit more and I'm not
going to be as price competitive and so
you need to be able to get that out and
so are you able to do that yourself or
maybe you need someone to help you you
know like if if you are great at talking
to clients on the phone one person but
you suck at writing then maybe you have
someone in your family or someone on
your team sitting with you on a phone
call and all of the good stuff that
you're saying they transcribe it and
turn it into an article that can be on
your page or just have so many interview
you say why don't you start this
business why does cleaning me so much to
you what do you hoping to accomplish
with this because it sounds like there's
a lot more to it then you know I don't
know I just I'm just cleaning to make
money right like give me the give me the
story behind it and that will attract a
lot more customers and if you're not
able to tell your story properly then
partner up with somebody and again just
somebody in your family someone who's on
your team already to help get that story
out of you so then you can market it
effectively you'll have to do it once to
be able to put it up on your website and
I would also make sure you have your
picture up doesn't have to be super
professional it could be you with your
team or you with your family or you with
your cleaning supplies whatever it is
most people have such boring websites
such boring about pages and you're
trying to be super professional and
corporate but then I can't connect with
you right I'm always gonna pick the big
corporate guy who has the reputation and
history and track record instead of you
your competitive advantage is your story
and the passion and feeling like you
know I work with you Renee I'm gonna I'm
working with a man of integrity and so
that's going to make a big difference
for me totally all right holy cow the
questions are coming in like crazy
someone is asking King Helios is asking
what's your definition of integrity so
again we're get a little deep there the
Final Four
so right
question I love this so my definition of
integrity is doing the things at which
come natural to you feel natural to you
that do not compromise any of your
values in any way however when we're
talking about selling with integrity the
natural part is important so men and
women are different I got to do is look
at men and women tell that we're
different right
our brains are different our DNA is
different so women are gonna sell
different than men we just are and
selling with integrity means means
staying in a sales process that is true
to you Evans gonna sell different than
me I'm gonna sell different than okra
everybody's gonna sell differently
nobody no two people still the same so
the point here is when you're selling
and integrity you're doing what's
authentic and what's real to you and
maybe I'm a better communicator than
person X and so that is the way I sell
maybe Grant Cardone is better at pushing
people and really selling through
pressure if that's what's authentic to
him then that is selling with integrity
I believe that everybody has their own
sales guardrail so you think you're
driving down the road and there's a
guardrail to keep you from going off you
know off the cliff right and so on one
side of that sales guardrail is really
really pushy and on the other side of
that sales guardrail is really passive
your sales guardrail is when you are
communicating right against that
guardrail without going over into to
Kushi and without going over into to
passive and we're all different so it's
gonna be a different mark for everybody
but I think you're communicating with
integrity and selling with integrity
when you're within your guardrail I
think I think you know when you're not
doing the right thing I think people
know when they're not doing the right
thing it's easy to know like you just
have that feeling in your stomach I'm
not doing the right thing I did you see
the justify like oh but if I do it I'm
able to pay my mortgage or me able to
get that new car I'm able to buy my new
dress or suit or whatever but you know
you know when you're doing something
wrong it's just having the courage to to
listen to that and know that you may
lose out on a short short term
Plus to win in the long term anyway my
dad's ah what is this l oj FitClub
alright hi guys my name is torie my
question is even if you have a
beneficial product positive service or
product you think that you should still
push the cell on potential clients this
kind of comes to your guardrail like
this like you really believe in your
product or service this is from Tory how
much do you push on a client wanna take
it or not so this is a great question I
think this goes back to what you were
just talking about I think it's how
comfortable you are pushing so here's
the thing people that we're selling to
are adults right we're not talking about
selling to minors at least most the
people I talk to or not we're talking
about selling to adults you cannot force
an adult to make a purchase they don't
want to make necessarily it's their
money so the idea that you have control
enough to push somebody into something
that they really don't want to do I
don't believe is accurate now you can
push until you're uncomfortable and that
is selling out of integrity but your job
as the seller is to communicate the
benefits of your product in your service
as passionately as you know how and as
honestly as you know how and then leave
it in the hands of the buyer the buyer
makes the decision so if again it goes
back to how comfortable you are pushing
some people are gonna be much more
comfortable going for a third and a
fourth and a fifth close I'm not
I sell as passionate as I can I go for
the close and if somebody needs to think
about it I do what most sales experts
would cringe at and I say great let me
know what questions you come up with I
want to help you make the best decision
for you at this time so it's it I think
it's an individual issue here I think
it's how comfortable you are but at the
end of the day the idea that you can
push somebody and to buy something that
they don't want I don't believe it's
true we're adults Tory for me it comes
down to intent
what's the reason behind the push if
it's just you can meet your sales quotas
you know for me that's not acting with
integrity that is a very self-serving
and I get the pressure that you can be
under to you know make rent and all that
if you genuinely believe that you have
something that will help sometimes you
need to push people a little bit past
their comfort zones and you know I see
it with with our salsa business an
example an investor in the salsa
business and became an owner and
sometimes people Colleen and they're
their word and they're afraid and they
have all these questions they're not
sure if they'll you know they'll be a
fydd and what if what if I don't get the
moves right and all of these you know
concerns and fears and understanding why
they wants to do it in the first place
why are they here talking to you what
gold Atanas cheap maybe we can help them
do that maybe were the we're one of the
best people in the world to help them do
that or maybe not you know and turning
away business may be against all the
sales rules out there but I don't want
unhappy clients because it's just a
headache I don't want a client who I
pushed into a sale you know try my best
or you know or lied to them to make them
believe something and then we start
working together and I can't deliver on
the results that they want and you know
that going in you know that you can't
really do what they want but you're you
know you just get that contract I I hate
that because it just creates more
headache that you then you want having
unhappy clients sucks you know just at
the time it takes but like the emotional
drain I'm having people who are upset at
what you're doing and feeling like
you're not delivering on the value so
you know I'd be concerned about pushing
people for the wrong reasons but if you
actually believe that what you have is
the best thing to help solve their
problem they may need a little bit of a
push or guidance or a little bit extra
time then you might give somebody else
so I don't know that I don't know that
being pushy or not is there's one answer
for it it's more for me the intent that
you have behind it is it just for your
own selfish purposes or is it actually
to give the best thing out there for
your client
totally agree good all right
um lots of questions sin Sanskrit soothe
our Sanskrit soothe our what's your take
on direct phone marketing I've struggled
with that a lot clients just don't seem
interested yeah mm-hmm whoo I did that
for about a year and it's a special
person that can do that and do it well I
think that this goes back a little bit
to whatever was just talking about and
and this is one of the principles or
foundations of authentic selling which
is in order to sell authentically I I
need to believe in the difference that
my products or service is making so not
just believe in myself to go out and
achieve my dream which is magical in
itself but to believe in the difference
that my product or service is making in
the lives of others when your direct
marketing on the telephone when you're
cold calling you need to be sold on your
product you need to be passionate about
it for it to work you do not need to be
the person who is oh my gosh another
eight hours until I get to go home and
I'm gonna make another you know twenty
calls to pretend I'm busy I'm gonna call
my voicemail and hang up like that's
miserable for you that's not what life
is about it's miserable for the other
person on the end of the phone I think
the key to make that work is you gotta
be you gotta be sold on on what you're
selling you have to know the difference
than it makes and you got to be excited
to talk to people about it yeah at five
o'clock my favorite thing to do is not
to enter the phone and talk to somebody
who's trying to sell me something but I
guarantee you if I get somebody who's
excited somebody who's gonna start
talking to me about the benefits I'm
gonna give them more time than the
person who is just making their 200th
call for the day you can pick up on the
energy I haven't I have an interesting
way of marketing myself I guess so I
might be on the extreme and take what I
say with a grain of salt but like I
don't do sales I don't have I don't have
anybody doing sales and my businesses I
don't like just to that clients don't
seem interested I hate talking
clients were not interested just as a
general rule and it also speaks to just
me as a person like I'm not the guy
who's a natural networker who talks to
the person next to me on the plane and
reduce myself at conferences I'll only
go into conferences if I'm speaking on
the conference I'll never go just to be
an attendee so that really suits my
personality it might be much more of a
marketer than a salesperson the way I do
it is just I try to kick up a lot of
noise in my industry I try to create a
lot of content you know you guys are
watching because you like my content and
that gets me known and that brings me
opportunities to work with brains and to
work with you know book deals and all
this kind of stuff where every time I
tried to go out and knock on somebody's
door and say hey let's work together as
a big brand it's never worked and it's
probably cuz I'm a terrible salesperson
but I'm not I don't know I don't know if
I have much to give you on cold calling
I don't do it I'm not a I'm not a big
believer in it at least for me and I try
to create an environment where people
want to find me instead of me going out
trying to find people it just speaks my
personality so you probably lot learn a
lot more from Kendrick on that kind of
stuff and for me but yeah I think that
you know one of the things that that you
illustrate there is how you stay within
your integrity right you got to be the
beginning what it means to sell within
your integrity
you don't like knocking on doors that's
what she's doing that's what you said so
you found a way around it and that's
when you're selling with integrity
another foundation of authentic selling
is if you feel the ick factor find a
better way and that's what you've done
you find out what you found a way that
works for you you're extremely
successful but for somebody who's who's
got the job of telemarketing or picking
up the phone then you gotta believe got
to believe in the difference that it
makes I really believe that or it's just
another job and that's not what this
life's about and that's not gonna sell
anything either on top of that yeah for
anything for any job you have you have
to love what you're doing like so many
people in the network marketing come up
to me and say hey how do I pull my
products like well do you use your
products absolutely would you recommend
to your mom using this face cream that
you're trying
so yeah so if you're in it just just to
make a paycheck you're not gonna have
success in anything wait whether it's
cold calling or anything else in any in
the entrepreneurial sphere especially
you got a you got to be connected to the
work that you're doing not to just be
chasing the goal but enjoy the process
absolutely without a doubt Michaels
writing in about attracting a partner he
wants to run the company and take care
of daily logistics and he wants a
partner who can go and hunt customers
because he hates doing that so advice on
on finding partners who can sell with
integrity from Michael I love that
Michael said hunt customers like that
makes me want to put all my goals that
are camouflage and go out and you know
yeah so Michael I think the thing to ask
yourself is first of all how do you like
to be sold to their various ways to sell
if somebody's going to be an extension
of your company or your brand or be out
doing the hunting and gathering of
customers if you will how do you like to
be sold to and what do you want the
representation to be for your company
the next thing is how do you how do you
find somebody who sells with integrity
part of that is gonna be the way they
interviewed for the job I mean I really
believe when somebody is acting out of
integrity and when they show up you know
you get that gut feeling that Evan
talked about earlier right you just know
in your stomach something's a little off
or this person seems really on top of
their game I want to know more something
else you can do and I hated this I hated
this but one of the things that I had to
do in one of my pharmaceutical sales
interviews um man gave me just a generic
ink pen there what anything special
about the pin and I'm sure you all heard
this and said sell me this pin right and
what you learned by that exercise is do
people make stuff up about the pin I
mean they're on the spot it's a job
interview do they embellish about the
pin how do they think on their feet
about the pin so you're gonna find a
true salesperson when you do this other
people are gonna
hate it but you're also gonna see what
people say about the pin and do they
embellish and are they selling this
generic pin that you can buy at the
dollar store out of integrity very cool
from for me partnerships can be a great
way to go I would just too many people
jump and do partnership way too soon you
know you're gonna spend as much time
with your partners you with your husband
or wife it's it's it's a relationship
yeah this has to work and so
understanding each other's values is
super important to what isn't what is
integrity mean to them you know what
does it mean to you
just like when you're marrying somebody
you want to make sure you match up on
and I use and important things in life
that you want to agree on where I think
two people jump into into relationships
because oh well I can do the ops and I
could do the business stuff and you can
be out there selling our skills match up
really well so let's form this
partnership and that is only half of the
equation if that where you want to make
sure you aligned on the values and so a
great way to do it is to start with a
small test you know if you want if
there's somebody that you think might be
a good fit just do one small thing
together before giving up equity in your
business do one small test and see how
that works well together the other thing
to think about is like if you can't find
that person that's not game over you
know I don't have a sales person in my
business you can build it up through
marketing so there's a lot of different
ways to build a business the sales can
be the path finding that right partner
can be the path I like that you're not
just trying to think how can I be the
salesperson if you're not great at sales
you don't really want to do it and you
feel like I have to force myself to do
it
I like that you're thinking have
somebody else come be an employee but
just those two things make sure you're
relying on the values and if you can't
find that person find another way to
stay cool it's crazy how quickly half an
hour goes by out of control can you want
to learn more about you find out about
all your things that you're up to your
shows and upcoming podcasts and all that
awesome stuff
what's the best way for them to I reach
it yeah it's Kendrick show calm KN DRI
ck sh ope calm and there are links to
contact me through Facebook or Twitter
or whatever there and yeah if there are
additional questions send them my way
I love sales questions I am the exact
office that I thrive all that stuff like
this I send them my way that was loud
cool well I linked up Kendricks
information in the description kendrick
thank you so much at the time thank you
guys for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon bye thank you so
much